hey how are you i am so good how are you
mercedes is so i'm so excited to talk to
you today i love you
i love you it truly is an honor you are
just someone that i have always followed
looked up to and you i'm so glad you're
gonna be back on the stage you're
performing this weekend tell us a little
bit about the show uh one of the things
that i am doing this year
mostly weekends because i'm doing a lot
of things right now but um to promote
the album and to do this kind of music
it's going to have a symphony with it
now what does that mean that doesn't
mean i'm not going to do paper roses or
meet me in montana or any of those but
usually it's all synthesized behind you
like the show in vegas is you know you
hear all the instruments this will be
the actual
instruments behind me and so the the
sound is going to be incredible um we
have the southern utah university
symphony bringing some of their people
in
it's going to be uh
some young kids that are doing it giving
them the opportunity it's just going to
be it's going to be a great show do you
remember though when you first started
what that moment was where you were like
whoa i think i'm i think i made it was
there a moment where it kind of hit you
like i think i
might be a success in this industry when
i knew
uh we were in paris
and um
i was the novelty in the show but my dad
he said hey your record paper roses went
to number one
go buy an outfit you're going to perform
it when we get back to the u.s and so
first place i performed it was at
madison square garden in in new york and
that's when i felt like whoa this is um
this is my success
you know this isn't
uh a brother's success and then of
course later on uh i was doing country
and donnie had some pop and then they
put us together and we did our show
together but but that's really
when it clicked in that i wanted to do
it one final question you and your
brother had a very successful residency
here in town will we ever see marie back
in vegas on stage
um
residency i'm not sure
uh
maybe some things in the future i'm kind
of enjoying this year is the first year
of my life mercedes
that i have said i want to spend time
with my husband you know we we took 25
years apart i remarried my first husband
and for the this year is dedicated of
course i'll be doing
tours sporadically so this will probably
be the closest show i do to vegas is the
laughlin one so come see it
but um i got a motorcycle
i have a harley
and um we i'm going to sturgis
you are
you know what can i say
who can see the